[Music]
some are longer than a blue whale others
are barely larger than a grain of sand
one species unleashes one of the most
deadly venoms on earth
another holds a secret that's behind
some of the greatest breakthroughs in
biology
they've inhabited the ocean for at least
half a billion years and they're still
flourishing as the sea changes around
them
jellyfish are soft bodied sea creatures
that aren't really fish they're part of
a diverse team of gelatinous ZOA
plankton Zoe plankton being animals that
drift in the ocean there are more than a
thousand species of jellyfish and many
others that are often mistaken for them
a noted feature of jellyfish is a
translucent Bell made of a soft delicate
material called meza glia sandwiched
between two layers of skin the mazzaglia
is more than 95% water held together by
protein fibers the jellyfish can
contract and relax their bells to propel
themselves they don't have a brain or a
spinal cord but a neural net around the
bells inner margin forms a rudimentary
nervous system that can sense the oceans
currents and the touch of other animals
jellyfish don't have typical digestive
systems either these gelatinous
carnivores consume plankton and other
small sea creatures through a hole in
the underside of their bells the
nutrients are absorbed by an inner layer
of cells with waste extruded back
through their mouths
but the jellyfish is relatively simple
anatomy doesn't prevent it from having
some remarkable abilities one kind of
box jellyfish has 24 eyes scientists
think it can see color and form images
within its simple nervous system four of
its eyes are curved upward on stalks
this allows the jellyfish to peer
through the surface of the water looking
for the canopy of the mangrove trees
where it feeds in fact this may be one
of the only creatures with a 360-degree
view of its environment the jellyfish's
sting which helps it capture prey and
defend itself is its most infamous
calling card in the jellies epidermis
cells called nematocysts like coiled
like poisonous harpoons when they're
triggered by contact they shoot with an
explosive force it exerts over 550 times
the pressure of Mike Tyson's strongest
punch to inject venom into the victim
some jellyfish stings barely tingle but
others cause severe skin damage the
venom of one box jellyfish can kill a
human in under five minutes making it
one of the most potent poisons of any
animal in the world other jellyfish
superpowers are less lethal one species
of jellyfish glows green when it's a
jeté 'td mostly thanks to a bio
fluorescent compound called green
fluorescent protein or GFP scientists
isolated the gene for GFP and figured
out how to insert it into the DNA of
other cells there it acts like a
biochemical beacon marking genetic
modifications or revealing the paths of
critical molecules scientists have used
the glow of GFP to watch cancer cells
proliferate track the development of
Alzheimer's and illuminate countless
other biological processes developing
the tools and techniques from GFP has
netted three scientists a Nobel Prize in
2008 and another three into
thousand 14 but it's jellyfish who may
be the most successful organisms on
earth ancient fossils prove that
jellyfish have inhabited the seas for at
least five hundred million years and
maybe go back over 700 million that's
longer than any other multi-organ animal
and as other marine animals are
struggling to survive in warmer and more
acidic oceans the jellyfish are thriving
and perhaps getting even more numerous
it doesn't hurt that some can lay as
many as forty five thousand eggs in a
single night and there's some jellyfish
whose survival strategy almost sounds
like science fiction when the immortal
jellyfish is sick aging or under stress
it's struggling cells can change their
identity
the tiny Bell and tentacles deteriorate
and turn into an immature polyp that
spawns brand-new clones of the parent as
far as we know these are the only
animals who've found a loophole when
facing mortality that's pretty
sophisticated for species that are 95%
water and predate the dinosaurs
[Music]